monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur Weber merci de votre question
ça me permettra de faire le point sur
cette question effectivement du
glyphosate qui est parfois une question
un peu polémique et un peu caricaturé
alors je vais vous dire quelle est la
position de la France la position de la
France si c'est polémique et caricaturé
je tiens le redire je vais vous dire
quelle est la position de la France la
position de la France sur les produits
phytosanitaires c'est d'essayer de tenir
une trajectoire de réduction et cette
trajectoire de réduction pour la
première fois dans le quinana précédent
nous avons commencé à l'amorcer sur le
GL gphosate en particulier je rappelle
que sur la période je depuis 2017 nous
avons réduit les usages du glyphosate de
près de 27 % il y a aucun gouvernement
qui a été capable de le faire aucun
aucun ni compris ceux que vous soutenez
ni ceux dans le monde don dont vous
faites référence sur le glyphosate nous
sommes le seul pays avoir réussi à
réduire les usages et donc la position
de la France qui s'est exprimée dans le
débat communautaire je rappelle que
c'est une décision communautaire à
l'échelle de la commission la décision
ça a été de faire en sorte que partout
où on peut trouver des alternatives il
n'y a plus d'utilisation du glyphosate
possible il y a des situations il n'y a
pas d'alternative possible par exemple
dans l'agriculture de conservation des
sols alors on peut essayer de dire en
permanence il y a qu'à faucon on peut
dire en permanence des alternatives il y
en a mais parfois il faut reconnaître
qu'il y en a pas qu' a besoin de
recherche et donc nous sommes sur la
trajectoire de la réduction et par
ailleurs s'il n'y a pas de solution il
n'y a pas d'interdiction c'est la ligne
à laquelle nous nous sommes fixés et
c'est la ligne à laquelle nous nous
tiendront je reviens de je reviens de la
somme je reviens de la somme il y a en
tribune qui sont venus expliquer qu'il y
avait des solutions pour l'alternative
au néonicotinoï la vérité c'est que nous
les avons toujours pas on maintient la
position française sur l'interdiction
c'est pas ça le sujet mais c'est
beaucoup plus compliqué que vous n'y
pensez parlez-en àine parlez-en àine et
donc on a besoin de travailler sur les
solutions c'est le sens des moyens qu'on
met sur la recherche sur l'innovation
pour qu'on puisse au fur et à mesure
réduire en tout cas la France est le
seul pays au monde à tenir une position
de réduction sur les glyphosat et c'est
ça qu'on continuera à défendre
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]